POI musicality it's a term that's been
floating around to talk about the
evolution of poi as a dance and art form
but how exactly do we achieve musicality
with our po spinning I've been exploring
po dance through the lens of musicality
now for years and I'm here to give you
the cheat sheet on how to accomplish
just
that Drex here from Drex Factor po sh sh
in with you the love of pois spinning
and flow Arts to benefit your body and
brain and in this video I'm giving you
five different skill levels of exercises
to get you started on adding musicality
to your pois spinning by way of Rhythm
but before we dance or I mean dive in I
do want to just give a quick shout out
to the Friends of the channel big thanks
to dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys pyrro Tera light toys and Ultra poy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non- business friend of the channel
Becca Becken thank you so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission so it does need to be said right
from the jump that musicality is a
massive topic that I couldn't hope to do
justice to in just a single video but
what I am going to try and do is produce
a series of videos of which this is the
first one that'll tackle musicality from
a number of different angles from
playing with rhythm to looking at Melody
and lyrics There's a bunch of different
ways that we can plug into the music
that we're performing to so in this
video I'm going to be giving you five
different exercises that are going to
help you tune in to what I think is the
most fundamental and important part of
any piece of music that is the Rhythm
the beat underlying it and how you can
get your poy to move in concert to it
now for each of these exercises I'm
going to be starting you off with just
one trick to work on to develop your
Rhythm now it should be said each of
these tricks is being selected just as
an entry point or a Gateway because
there is no one py trick that conveys
Rhythm but there do happen to be a whole
family of different py tricks that have
properties in common with the one that
I'm sharing in each exercise so I'm
going to not only share with you that
one po trick but also embellish on it
and show you other P tricks that
accomplish the same goals I'm going to
give you these exercises in skill level
from beginner to intermediate and all
the way into advanced so that no matter
where you are in your flow Journey I've
got an exercise that I hope is going to
be helpful so let's dive in drill number
one beginner beat yes the Beat of the
Music is indeed what we're trying to key
into here but what I'm referring to in
this example is actually the beat of the
poy that is every time you spin it when
it hits a Down Beat or an upbeat and
trying to make sure that that coincides
with the Beat of the Music you can think
of this as the simplest way that the poy
can tie into the Beat of the Music after
all the very first thing we learned to
do with POI is just keep it spinning so
if we can do that in Tempo to the music
our audience is definitely going to pick
up on us working these two elements
together and so with that in mind the
trick that I'm going to have you use for
this first exercise is just a thread the
needle if you don't know how to do this
one I'm going to go ahead and include a
link to tutorial on it up in the cards
as well as down in the description deson
but essentially this is performing a
butterfly and just swapping which hand
is on top each time we're just going to
be doing this in time with the music all
right so now to add music but also to do
a little exercise that we're going to
need for each and every drill on this
list let me show you what I mean first
up
music cool so now I need to go ahead and
beat match the POI to the music that is
I need to find the precise length of the
POI that matches up every time I spend
the poy with the music without taxing me
too much so just to start
[Applause]
with at full length I can get the PO to
match up the bottom part of the beat
with the Down Beat of the Music and the
upper part of the beat with the uh
upbeat of the music not bad now if I go
to medium
length if I go real fast I can match
precisely with the beat of the song and
if I go to half
length I can hit every single beat but I
kind of want the this exercise to be a
more relaxed one so how about we go with
that full length feel sound
good 5 6 5 6 7 go
one not
bad and if you
feel inspired to add a little bit of
footwork that never goes a miss
you can also do this
exercise up around your ears with say
shoulder
reels a
[Music]
[Applause]
windmill or even a 3B
weave in each case you're just looking
to match up the Down Beat of the poy
with the Down Beat of the
Music awesome
drill number two beginner intermediate
stalls so I have to admit this is
probably my favorite tool for matching
the bead of the music I first keyed into
this by watching the work of G the
British po spinner who popularized the
use of plane brakes stalls are a great
compliment to the beat of any music
because well they already look really
percussive as is but really you should
think of stalls as being kind of a
placeholder here for any zero point
trick that is it could be stalls or
pendulums it could be Point isolations
shotguns you name it any moment where
you get the momentum of the PO to just
stop dead in its tracks just like a drum
beat for this exercise we're going to
keep things simple and just have Our
poise spin around and perform down
stalls on either size of our body with a
little beat in between them once again
that's to make sure that we're taking
care of that upbeat as well as the down
beats and once again I will include a
link to tutorial on this trick up in the
cards as well as down in the descript
description and I've already taken the
liberty of beat matching this song and I
know that I want to work with po there
about half length so let's add
[Music]
music 5 6 5 six 7
go and once again we can add some
[Music]
footwork I'm just doing little Coupes
with my feet as I go from side to side
[Music]
here and of course we can also do up
stalls or pendulums
[Music]
Point
isolations
shotguns and there you have it drill
number three intermediate volume volume
actually ties into the beat matching
exercise that I showed you in our first
drill namely the bigger the circle theoy
is traveling around the longer it takes
to get around it and therefore the more
possible beats it eats up we can use
this to our advantage by adding our arm
to the size of this circle and therefore
make the PO be able to switch instantly
back and forth between shorter beats and
longer beats we can use this to
emphasize specific beats in the Rhythm
all right so our po trick for this
exercise is going to be hip reels namely
hip rails in together opposites right
next to our hips here I of course am
spinning my POI in a reverse butterfly
where it's going outward and I'm
switching which hand is behind and in
front every single beat now I'm going to
count off 1 2 3 4 and on the one of
every measure boom whichever hand is in
front is going to do a much bigger
Circle an extension from my shoulder as
it works its way back that way I can be
seen to emphasize the beginning of every
single measure as I'm beat matching here
all right all right so now it's time to
add music so let's do
that oh fast and funky I like
that cool here we
go see how the big arm accentuates the
beginning of the
measure I can also add my foot in there
if I want
[Music]
we can also do this with some other
tricks like three be
WIS four
[Music]
windmills pretty cool huh drill number
four intermediate Advanced flowers
flowers are one of my favorite
challenges to match up with the music
and specifically I'm talking about those
moments when we hit the tips of the
petals inside those flowers if we were
to just stick with the beat formula from
our first exercise we would wind up with
a very different feel coming out of our
flowers because they tend to have an odd
number of down beats for the number of
petals that they have but if you focus
on when the petals themselves are being
performed it can suddenly become a
percussive moment and for this example I
am choosing my favorite flower of all
time that is split time opposites
anti-spin flowers and I'm going to try
and hit a beat at the tip of every
single petal like so you'll also note
I'm once again keeping things short
because I have already beat matched to
this song all right let's add music to
this one I've already taken the liberty
of putting it
[Music]
on notice how I'm having to speed up and
slow down just a hair in different parts
of the flower in order to get it to
match the beat which is totally
[Music]
fine we can also do this in Split Time
same
[Music]
direction as well as inpin
heck yeah drill number five Advanced
throws all right so it needs to be said
that every single exercise that we've
played with on this list involves taking
a petrick and making it feel
percussive and there are ways to make
poy tricks feel percussive that you
might not otherwise think such as when
they leave the control of your hand and
when they return to it as well throws
really are are the ultimate Challenge
when it comes to matching the rhythm of
the music the reason being that as soon
as they leave our hands we no longer
have control over them we have to hope
that we gave them enough speed and
enough energy to get through their throw
just in time so for this exercise we're
going to be using a repeating pattern
that's going to allow us to throw each
of our POI in turn it's going to use
inpin throws that is that type of throw
where we have the PO kind of tumbling
over its head in midair like it's
performing The Petal of an ins spin
flower the entire pattern is going to
look like this we're going to do a
pendulum out to one side with both Po
and as we come back we speed things up
just a little bit and have one po do an
ins spin throw as the other one does a
quick beat behind our back and when we
catch the POI we do a little pendulum
out to the side so throw beat pendulum
throw beat pendulum throw beat pendulum
throw beat pendulum like so all right so
let's add some music and see if we can
synchronize our throws to
it nice little funky to take us
home five six five six seven
[Music]
go you do have a little bit of leeway
and when you make the catch but not a
lot
[Music]
you can also do this with no beat
throws and switch back as you see fits
not going to lie throws are not my forte
but I did just want to demonstrate this
technique so there you have it friends
five different ways that you can start
to work on your Rhythm and musicality
with your POI to match up with the music
that you're listening to so clearly I
have just scratched the surface in this
video and if you're curious to learn
more I do have a way that you can go
deeper down the rabbit hole I teach po
dance classes live stream every Tuesday
on crowdcast I give my students
practical exercises that help hone their
musicality through a variety of
different drills and all the classes are
recorded So if for any reason you can't
make a class live you can always watch
the recording or go back and read
visited anytime you want to brush up on
the topics that we covered my next
session starts up on March 18th you can
sign up at the link down in the
description up in the cards or the one
listed on screen did you get anything
out of this video please make sure to
like share comment and subscribe to help
other people find it and to help my
channel grow
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you all of you
are awesome and if you out there
watching are not currently a supporter
but you like the content that I create
and you'd like to see me make more of it
the best way to make that happen is to
go sign up to support this work on
patreon over at
patreon.com drexfactor pooy there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards but better than that
you'll be helping me out in my mission
to bring po spinning and flow Arts to
the whole world so go check that out
please and thank you and if you're
interested in applying these lessons
I've done videos on how to write po
choreography that I'll go ahead and link
to down in the description as well as up
on screen thank you so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow today and
get some dance in there and I'll see you
with a new video real soon take care now
peace